is the whole phase necessary after
heartbreak and what
inspired this topic
is that sam over here just got out of an
eight-year relationship
yep
so when did that end
it's fresh in 2022 so if you through
january it all ended
what do you mean like through jet like
was
it was like
we'd sit down we'd have a chat
i didn't see things working or going
forwards
but then we try but the connection
sparks just wasn't there anymore and
things had happened in the past that
just didn't make me comfortable being
there anymore so
was it was it a distance thing like were
you no no we live together oh okay we
still live together wait you should live
with her i didn't tell you that yeah no
yeah so
london london living prices and all that
so
oh my god i was not expecting that how
does that work
it's a bit awkward
is it is it a two bedroom one bed i'm on
the sofa for the next few months until
the tenancy runs out do you guys like
date other people
well it's still fresh but
i don't know about her but i'm
out there again yeah and
oh my gosh i'm like i'm just imagining
like yeah okay
so we
sorry we should have mentioned it
earlier maybe
i i did not realize that okay so when
did you guys meet you met when she was
or you were you're 20 i'm 24 now yeah we
must have met
when we were 15 maybe okay
yeah and it took a couple years
and then we got together
and now it's
yeah done
and you said you broke it off right yeah
i broke it off um can i ask why
um
maybe not on here no no that's okay um
because it's kind of uncommon because i
was saying before usually girls initiate
breakups
um
but then why do they do that why why
does do why do girls end a relationship
um well
you're not in the red pill are you the
red pill yes you guys i mean by that yes
like do you know who rolo tomasi is
never you know have you heard of
hypergamy no yeah this is very like this
is a weird sector of youtube i'm gonna
warn you okay so hypergamy
means basically like if a woman settles
down with a guy
she has to see him as like the best that
she can do
so women often leave because they get
attention from other men and they think
they can do better
so
like oftentimes a girl is like moving on
to the next best thing
okay i'd say um it's hard to find the
next best thing from me
well it wasn't the case in that because
it was a relationship
yeah and maybe that was a little bit
from me instead yeah yeah yeah
i've also seen like i feel like if guys
date a girl super young it's like kind
of hard because they don't get to have
like their wild you know
yeah obviously like
together from 16 to 24 so yeah
i've never been wild wild yeah yeah
there's been thoughts
but
nothing crazy on a night out
yeah
so how does living with her work
like do you guys talk still
is it do you agree with each other like
at the start it's always been like you
know
how are things going to work out like if
we're both at home in the evening are we
going to have dinner together and stuff
yeah but our schedules at the moment
just
work so it's just only really one of us
at the house at a time
apart from at night
it's been manageable so far yeah and how
have you been doing like i can't ima i
cannot imagine that would wreck me i
would be done
after an eight-year relationship i would
be done
i think where is me that ended it i've
taken it much better
i
don't want to sound like a douche but
it feels like a weight off the shoulders
and somewhat moving on to happier things
yeah
okay so you're doing okay yeah i'm good
good do you so what do you think of the
title tonight
there's a few opinions on it
um
but
is it necessary
i'd say it's a personal thing it's a
personal thing yeah
do you think it's different between the
sexes
100 okay so what do you think for guys
and for girls in general it doesn't have
to be specific
i'd say from a guy's perspective
coming out the relationship
yes i downloaded tinder straight away
but then
where do you bring them yeah where do i
bring them too
but like you know it's not getting to
every friday night and i'm not out in
shoreditch like yeah let's try to get
this
like
girl
yeah
obviously the end of the relationship
the last few months there's been no
sexual relationship
but
what not so much but
oh no wonder you get like
obviously there's a need but i wouldn't
say it's
something i'm going out there to look
for and fulfill
but i'm open-minded now and just looking
for what do i want in life
i feel like the whole phase is bad for
girls
i think it kind of like mentally
it doesn't like do well i think girls
have like more consequences for a whole
face than a guy
there can be more consequences yeah like
i feel like girls
aren't really like meant to do that
but is anyone meant to do it
biologically yeah men are
because you have to think like back in
the day like men are more programmed to
like spread their seed where women are
programmed to find the best quality mate
that they can
yeah in general in general yeah
that rubs you the wrong way i can see it
in your eyes
no it's that is history that is
evolution and stuff so yeah
but i'd say also today we live
in a very sexualized society
where
particularly from like the age of 16 to
21
it seems everyone just wants to shag
no i um
well it's different because
in the old days like people would
get married so young and find their
partner so young
but nowadays the average age in the uk
of first marriage what do you think it
is
nowadays
yeah
probably
late 20s
it's 31 for women 31 for women like 32
for men
yeah in the us it's like 28 for women 29
for men
okay
but
marriage is dying out as well i'd say
yeah i'm not particularly bothered about
getting
married but obviously i do want to have
a long lasting relationship
that is someone i love
but
at the end of the day marriage just a
piece of paper
what is marriage
what is merit
well we actually we talk a lot about
marriage on the channel because it
doesn't particularly benefit men and i
think men are kind of walking away from
marriage
because it's like there's no 50 50.
yeah like i don't think that's fair to
guys actually like um like if i was to
marry someone and get divorced like i
could file for what is it called
when even if we didn't have a kid like i
could file for like they'd still have to
pay me just for being married yeah wow
i'm like that's that's crazy and even
with kids like that's the number one
reason nba players go broke
you get the wrong girl pregnant
wow
you gotta be careful with you yeah
then
when you're famous
you can afford it
oh no that's why they go not if they're
taking 50 of your income
i'd happily be on
six seven figures and lose 50 of it
yeah but no a lot of people that get
rich quick don't really have the money
skills to like sustain it you know what
i mean like they just spend it all yeah
buy a house by cars yeah
true
try live a lavish lifestyle
so um how long were you thinking about
the breaking up with her before you did
was she like blindsided or did she kinda
you know see it coming
i think she was a little bit blindsided
but i'd say
the last couple of years were a struggle
but really where i just felt
it had to end
probably
end of december started january okay
yeah now i need to get out of this and
did she see it coming
i don't think so no no was she really
sad
yeah she was yeah
she still
struggles with it and yeah
she went away
for a week
and she did call me while she was away
i was like
how are things going to work living in
the flat together still
what if you start getting feelings for
me again stuff like that i was like
i just don't see having it at all like
you don't need to worry about that
okay i probably didn't feel that
savagely
don't worry i'm good
so you have no feelings at all after
eight years
obviously i still
like like
nothing bad happens to her i'm a decent
human i'm not yeah yeah
but
in terms of a relationship and spark
there's just nothing there no more yeah
i don't see any of it coming back
because
what has happened
to that
i asked you before the stream i know
anything you don't want me to
ask and i was told no
true right yeah you were except that
yeah except that
okay so what have you
so it was kind of like emotionally you
were kind of like done before the
relationship ended
yeah which is why i've probably found it
easier yeah
to move on that's how it was um because
i just got out of a relationship in like
december and i think i was thinking
about breaking up with him for like two
months because you broke up with him
what you broke up with him no i did yeah
i did but i was still really sad because
i didn't really like
want to
but it's like
i kind of had to to be honest so
was that long distance is he in the
states yeah i use it in the states so i
guess i think it was
the second i came here it was kind of
like
doomed we tried but you know yeah
because we were sort of
semi-long-distance-ish at the start of
the relationship yeah
two three hour car journey which is
obviously not quite the states from
london but
things worked fine then
but
[ __ ] happened
[Music]
gosh it sounds
is it cheating no no no no no no no i
did not she was aware she's never
cheated on me yeah